[Music]
good evening and welcome to covert and
the classroom a special program
where we hear from young people about
the impact the pandemic is having on
their education
and their well-being well on monday the
prime minister will set out his roadmap
for lifting coronavirus restrictions in
england
and has previously said that reopening
schools was a national priority
well the extent of the problem is clear
there are around 8.9 million school
children in england
of those the latest figures show that
894
000 children are of critical workers and
are attending school
an average child's already missed 114
days of school that's half an academic
year
and by the end of the pandemic a young
person could have seen
five percent of their academic career
affected and this will have an impact on
their prospects and their well-being
the institute for fiscal studies
calculates that the average young person
could see a loss
of 40 000 pounds in income over their
lifetime
and without government intervention that
could add up to a total of 350 billion
pounds in lost
lifetime earnings and on the issue of
mental health
the children's commissioner for england
has reported that one in six
children aged between five and 19
has a mental health disorder last year
that's up from one in eight
three years earlier well in the face of
these problems the government are
pumping in money to support children and
young people with 1 billion
pounds to fund a catch-up premium and a
national tutoring program
but some believe this is inadequate
well over the past few weeks we've been
hearing from young people and their
parents about their experiences of
education during lockdown
and on the eve of the prime minister's
announcement we've revisited some of
them to find out what they want boris
johnson to
address and then we'll be getting the
view from our expert panel
tonight david laws who's chairman of the
education policy institute and former
schools minister will be joining us
as well as rachel warwick a former
president of the association for school
and college leaders and the executive
head teacher at ridgeway education trust
and to get the clinical perspective
we'll also be joined by the gp
dr ellie cannon a very warm welcome to
all of you
but first let's start the program with
our first question from 13 year old
brooke norbury should pupils get weekly
tests for coronavirus
okay short and sweet question there to
you first of all rachel warwick because
this has been
the subject of the day between the
unions in the department of education
whether it should be done by
teachers or whether it should be done by
parents what's your view
i think we need to follow the science um
and
that's something we've been saying um at
association with school and college
leaders
all the way through this crisis and we'd
like to hear more from the scientists
first of all about the efficacy of
lateral flow tests which is contested
and actually some understanding about
the logistics which are required
to test children in school for example
one of the secondary schools in our
trust has sixteen hundred children
it would take us two weeks um to test
all of them
twice with three day intervals um as has
to happen for lfd testing
and we're happy to do that as long as we
know it's really
going to make a difference it's going to
be accurate enough to
make all of the young people and staff
in school feel
reassured about coming back into schools
very soon
and dr ellie cannon do you think this is
going to be a useful tool and just on a
practical level how easy is it going to
be
certainly for little ones to have weekly
tests
well certainly lateral flow tests are
pretty straightforward but rachel's
absolutely right
in very large schools how
is that actually going to be feasible
and with
any intervention in terms of health
and natural flow testing we would regard
as a non-pharmaceutical intervention
we always talk about the benefits versus
the risks
so it sounds like a good idea to be
testing kids
um every week every other week to look
for
cases but actually is it a good idea is
the efficacy there
is it proven that actually um then
quarantining those children
is going to be of benefit both to the
child and
also the community transmission
and are the tests good enough for that
purpose and this
really needs to be clarified by the
government and by the scientific
advisors
okay and let's bring in david laws on
this point there's a lot of pressure on
the government to get this right
schools need to stay open now don't they
could this be a useful tool in making
that work
it could certainly be a useful tool but
i agree very much with the two other
guests that we need to think through the
practicalities of this
and it's surprising to me that just
three or four days before
the government plans to announce what
its strategy is for reopening schools on
the 8th of march
there still seem to be quite detailed
discussions and controversies about this
it's going to be an enormous challenge
for schools or for parents if this is
going to go ahead
and really there needs to be more notice
in this area
and in other areas so that schools have
a proper chance to plan
okay not to say it can't happen of
course we've seen haven't we the huge
success of the vaccine rollouts
well let's move on now to our next
question and this is about the crucial
issue of the future of exams we've had a
few on this
let's take a listen do you believe that
it will be fair to make the 2022 exam
cohort set a full examination series
next year
given the impacts on their education
since march of 2020
and if so how would you justify that
with the discrepancies in
education due to digital poverty
what is being done to help the year 11
and year 12s
who have heightened anxiety sitting
exams due to the fact that they weren't
able to sit their gcses
okay let's bring david in on this first
of all are we going to see
real differences do you think in exam
results as a result of those
disparities in remote learning
yes we're certainly going to see a very
big difference in the amount of learning
that young people
have and that's one of the reasons why
the government eventually decided to
scrap
formal exams this year and to rely upon
teacher grading so they could take into
account to some extent the lost learning
over the last year or so and not
actually penalize students who have lost
a lot of learning time
for the way in which they may have
suffered now there's a key question as
your first question have put to us
about whether or not exams on a full
curriculum will be able to go ahead
uh in 2022 and i think that depends
crucially on whether or not we manage to
get all students back
on the 8th of march and whether pupils
stay
back in school now on a permanent basis
if they do it's possible that we would
be able to catch up some of the learning
for
those who will take their exams in 2022
and we might be back to a normal
examination series covering most of the
curriculum
but if students lose a lot more time
over the months ahead
and are going back and forth to in and
out of school
for the rest of this year then we might
need other contingency plans for 2022
and we ought to have those well worked
out again in advance so that
um teachers and and school children are
not suddenly landed with big changes
where they don't actually know what the
plans are
for a few weeks or a few months ahead
and on the second uh question
about getting students used to exams
who've missed their
uh gcses and who've had a very different
learning experience this year
i mean i think if exams are going to go
ahead in 2022
the normal gcses and a levels then it's
a good
challenge to schools that they will need
to get
their pupils used to taking those exams
obviously schools are very good at that
they're very
used to having mock and other
examinations and that will be
a way of allowing students who have
missed gcses
to prepare properly for their a levels
okay so a lot of it will depend on how
quickly we can get
students back into the classroom i want
to bring in rachel and i want to talk
about
the a word not in terms of grades but of
course
algorithms no one wants to see the
return of those do they
no um what we don't want to see is a
repeat of what happened last summer
most of all for the young people who are
waiting for
who are due to take some form of
assessment for their gcse's a level or
vocational qualifications this summer
i think i just go back to david's point
about timeliness
um we haven't had a lot of forward
notice from government
about the changes we've been asked to
manage in schools and colleges
despite that i think we've done a good
job um in terms of being responsive and
agile
but um with reference to a first
question
i would say that we do need some
mitigation for the 2022 exams
because of the differential learning
loss which the current year 10
and year 12 have already suffered and we
really do need to know what that would
look like if we're going to have
some curtail content for exams for
example
before the summer holiday so that
teachers have time to plan
the curriculum appropriately for when
students come back in september
so their experience is measured and they
feel reassured that teachers
always acting their best interests have
had the time to prepare and to make sure
that the work that they're doing is
really going to pay off for them
when it comes to those exams in 2022.
and of course dr ellie i know you'll
have picked up on the word anxiety being
used in that second question there i
know it's an issue as a gp that you're
seeing
with youngsters let's just before i get
some response from you on that
here from 16 year old emily harris she's
got a point to make about youth services
and is really worried about it
i think it's really important that we
don't underestimate the impact that
youth services are and will be having on
young people
in lockdown and post lockdown and one of
the things that's
kind of causing a lot of anxiety in
myself at least and probably
a lot of other young people is the
possibility of
change when lockdown ends
so i think one of the things that's
making me most anxious
is the idea that now that i've become
accustomed to this kind of support from
youth services
when we come back to school that kind of
support will evaporate and the change
i don't know how well i will be able to
adapt to the change
or how well a lot of other young people
will be adapting to the change
and that's quite a scary prospect
and you can really hear the worry in her
voice there ellie and look whether it's
about
lock down ending and the change that's
coming or whether it's in having to face
exams not feeling like they're ready for
it
how worried are this generation of kids
are you finding
oh they're incredibly worried and
anxiety
is just one of the many mental health
problems that you alluded to in your
introduction
um 20 of children are now
suffering with a mental health problem
and they are just the ones who have
actually reported it
and been counted i'm sure that actually
there are many many more who go
under the radar and that's very worrying
um young people have had their lives
turned absolutely
upside down and they have not been
prioritized in the last year
obviously we're talking about schools
now but
their whole lives have been turned
upside down their relationship with
their peers
their ability to do physical exercise
their ability to go on and achieve the
milestones they want to whether that
is taking on an apprenticeship or
leaving school or whatever it is
and we have to be incredibly mindful of
that
going forward there are too many adults
and too many people
who um are experts who talk about
children young people being resilient um
and bouncing back and i think um
the teenager who just asked the question
perfectly illustrates that actually
many young people are not resilient and
we can't just expect them to bounce back
just like we wouldn't expect an adult to
bounce back
it's been one of the big paradoxes of
the whole pandemic hasn't it that the
children who are actually least affected
by this virus have actually had to pay
one of the biggest prices
let's move into our next question now
this is from 13 year old
hinogoto all my cousins living in japan
haven't missed a day of school
japanese schools have remained open
throughout the pandemic
teachers and students there wear face
masks all day long including during
lessons
and lunches taken in classrooms so that
kids don't face one another while eating
here in the uk i'm wondering why we're
only required to wear face masks in the
hallways and not inside the classrooms
too
okay well let's ask david laws his views
on this i mean it's quite extraordinary
to think that their schools have stayed
open throughout
all of this in japan certainly for the
kids here in the uk totally different
experience could we have done things
differently of their lessons to be
learned from our
international neighbours
i think there are certainly a lot of
lessons for us to learn as a country not
just about how we've managed this
in the education system but across the
whole of
society and we looked pretty uh slow
moving as a country early on in the
pandemic to take some of the actions
that we needed to take
it was also controversial obviously how
we should deal with some of the
protective elements around this and as
you know not just in schools but outside
schools the advice on
whether people should wear face masks at
all
changed hugely in the first six months
of the pandemic
so i think that this is a perfectly
sensible question to ask should we be
following other countries
in using face masks more in school
we know that policy has evolved in this
area but that really is
has got to be one for the medical
experts who advise the government on
these matters
and it's important as far as possible
that they that we follow their advice
and look at the latest evidence that
we've got about for example the way
the virus transmits between young people
and the way that the virus translates
outside school between young people and
older people so we need to follow the
medical advice on this
okay it's going to be a work in progress
as well isn't it okay david thanks for
that
let's move on to our next questions
we've got so many i want to make sure we
get through as many as we can
this is from 13 year old india sethi
given the fact we may be going back to
school in three weeks time
when should our wonderful teachers get
vaccinated
oh long may that enthusiasm for teachers
continue hey rachel
do you think that teachers should be
bumped up the priority list
i think it was entirely appropriate that
the vulnerable the elderly and nhs
frontline workers were prioritized
in the first instance of vaccination and
i know many many of my colleagues do in
teaching as well
but we do feel now in the second phase
that vaccinations should be prioritized
by occupation
there are just under a million teaching
and support staff
in schools in england and i think the
risk of those
people working in crowded schools where
there's very little social distancing
possible and in primary schools where
there is no social distancing between
students and staff
is very different to someone perhaps in
their 50s
who's working from home and is not going
to
expose themselves to a similar type of
risk so for me
to give reassurance to staff in our
schools for whom i feel responsible and
there's a duty of care
i really do think that there should be
some urgent thought
given to um prioritizing teachers and
educational support staff in this
country for vaccination now
um as soon as possible yes i mean it's a
phrase that's used a lot we talked about
it earlier about following the science
certainly
dr ellie cannon the government say that
the jcvi believe that
not profession but age should be the
most important factor when deciding
who gets the vaccine and not just age
but also clinical condition
yes and that's absolutely right but at a
time when
first of all we are doing incredibly
well in terms of the vaccination program
and many people now are being offered
the vaccination around
the age of 50 so we are actually moving
down the groups quite fast in some parts
of the country
and also bearing in mind what we've
already talked about which is
children have given up a huge amount in
the last
year and have been put at risk they've
not been put at risk from
covid thankfully but they've been put at
risk
from loss of physical development
from effects to their mental health
children who are vulnerable in terms of
the support they get from school that's
not been there
so we need to look at ways to mitigate
that risk
now it might be that vaccinating
teachers
if you simply weighed it up against the
other jcvi
groups cannot be justified but we have
to look at vaccinating teachers
holistically in terms of the fact that
getting children back to school now is a
priority
and therefore if there is groundswell
from
teachers to feel more comfortable by
being vaccinated
it's certainly a safe measure then we
should be considering
prioritizing them in order to then
prioritize
schools reopening okay interesting point
thank you very much
it is important to stress i should say
that boris johnson will only be setting
out a plan for schools in england when
he speaks next week there are of course
different timetables
for the different nations of the uk so
as india was saying in her question in
england as it stands
all schools will continue with remote
learning until march the 8th
at the earliest although boris johnson
may have more details
next week in scotland the government's
announced a phased return to school from
the 22nd of february so that's this
coming monday
and similarly in wales schools will
begin a phased return for foundation
phase learners that's three to
seven-year-olds from the same date
whilst in northern ireland today it was
announced that some primary school
pupils will return on march the 8th
and exam pupils will go back on march
the 22nd
now our next question is from 14 year
old trey corliss
if the plan to open schools by the 8th
of march
goes ahead will the government be taking
a risk if people haven't received their
second dose of the vaccine
i want to put this question to ellie
because i know that you've personally
actually been involved
in one of the vaccine trials what's your
view on the
interdose interval is it a bit of a risk
no it's not a bit of a risk in terms of
um
the public health emergency that we are
in and the first dose um both of fisa
and of astrazeneca
gives a very good level of immunity and
in order to
get that population immunity up actually
it's better to get a large number of
people given their first dose
than it is a smaller number of people
both doses and of course people are
going to get their second dose
it's just going to be around the 12-week
mark
transmission is probably going to happen
in schools there are almost 10 million
children at school
um so of course once we send children
back to school there is going to be
some level of transmission and that's
why we have to
take this slowly keep everything else
closed
so we can open schools and so we can
actually see
how it goes that doesn't mean that
transmission is particularly high
in schools it's just a reflection of
what else is going on
so if schools are open and nothing else
is open of course you're going to see
transmission in schools vaccination
should be
helping all of this and is already
being shown to reduce severe disease and
hospitalization so i'm optimistic
that having already achieved 17 million
vaccine doses in this country actually
that can only help us get the kids back
to school
okay let's bring in david at this point
and both vaccine questions to you really
whether you think that teachers should
be in line and whether you're worried
about the gap
between the first and the second dose in
terms of kids going back to school
i'm not worried about the strategy of
vaccinating as many people as possible
with the first dose that does seem to be
sensible and based on the medical
evidence
of course there is some risk that by
having children go back before
all of the vulnerable groups have have
had their second vaccination
there is a higher risk than if we shut
things down for much longer
and insisted that everybody had had
their second vaccinations before
young people went back to school but the
problem is that we have to manage the
balance of risks in our society
and there are enormous risks from having
eight or nine million children
out of school for months and months on
end to their future prospects to the
country's prospects
and to their mental health so i think
that what the government is doing
by seeking to reopen on the 8th of march
makes sense
but of course there are some risks
around it and then on the
issue of whether teachers should be
vaccinated as a priority in the next
stage
i agree very much with what rachel said
about the government being right to
start with the older groups and those
with
underlying medical and health conditions
once we get into the second phase of the
roll out of the
of the vaccinations i do think that
there is a case
for looking at prioritizing some of the
groups such as teachers who have to go
out into the workplace at this time and
are more likely to be exposed to the
virus
compared with people like me who are
able to work perfectly happily from
from home i would in a sense prefer that
a teacher was vaccinated in preference
to somebody
who wasn't in a vulnerable group and was
working from home
but medical advisors will need to input
it into that decision with government
and then also need to tell government
whether it's practical
to differentiate between people in other
occupations it's probably quite easy for
the nhs to identify
older people and those with health
conditions and and call them in
whether it's as easy to go through
different high-risk occupations
uh is an issue that we need practical
advice on
from those who are running the national
health service
okay let's get a final thought now find
a couple of thoughts
on well-being and support for young
people
so i know there has been a lot of
anxiety within students about what our
gcse grades are going to be and our
a-level grades
luckily enough for me i had support for
my mental health from action for
children
but i was wondering what schools are
willing to do
to support students as we come out of
does the lockdown feel it's a sensible
approach for schools to include
positive mental well-being for pupils as
a part of the curriculum
perhaps with more outside classes
ah they're lovely perhaps with more
outside classes but there's
a serious point in all of this you know
what could the legacy be from this
pandemic not just in terms
of well-being but you know how the kids
can can learn from it all
to you rachel well i agree
with your speakers i've had some great
ideas um we know that being outside
sport art music dance the social
connection which means that which being
in a school community brings
is really healthy for young people that
well-being should be built into our
school communities not bolted on
and i don't know a head teacher in the
country who isn't thinking really hard
about their well-being strategy for
young people
and i think that will at its center be
about listening to young people in the
way that we have on this program tonight
and actually listening to their worries
so that we're responding
to you know where they are um in their
return to school in this process if we
connect
which we're all as teachers and support
staff really looking forward to
um no teacher enjoys teaching over a
laptop okay
i'm sorry to interact we're just about
to run out of time ellie sorry a final
quick thought from you on that as well
absolutely i mean school is about so
much more than education
it's about mental health physical
activity for some kids it's about
food and avoiding some of the aspects of
poverty
and i think this pandemic should have
really brought that home
to all of us as adults and it absolutely
has to be a priority
coming out of the pandemic okay thank
you so much sorry to rush you all there
but i'm afraid that is
all we have time for on this edition of
covid and the classroom so
all that's left for me to do is thank
our panel this evening
david laws rachel warwick and ellie
cannon thank you very much and also
thank you
to all of our contributors who sent in
their questions from home
and to you for watching us do remember
though we have full coverage of bryce
johnson's announcement on
the way ahead that's right here on sky
news on monday